un coup de force du parti islamiste
ennahda qui a réuni ses participants et
ses adhérents il sera capitale tunis
elle mourut de manifestations en soutien
à ce parti islamiste ennahda et surtout
on soutient monsieur ghannouchi le
président de leur fils le président de
l'assemblée nationale en tunisie qui
nous menacé de destitution après dès
samedi de manifestations contre ce parti
islamiste ennahda qui l'ont coco cola
qu'à quelques l'on accuse d'être à la
tête de tous les maux de la société d'un
point de vue économique politique mais
aussi le sanitaire un rendez vous ici
sont ils de 40 millions de personnes qui
sont venues des quatre coins de la
tunisie de parme il ya même à prêter 75
voire 70 pour amener tous ses adhérents
nouveau dans une dynamique où un énorme
pendant de sécurité organisés ici sur
cette avenue mohamed ziegler à l'avenue
habib bourguiba
une autre manifestation a été organisée
de l'autre côté de la ville par le parti
travailliste
la partie le parti de gauche qui est
contre ce parti islamiste ennahda les
forces de l'ordre essaient de quadriller
ce périmètre pour éviter que ces deux
manifestations puissent se croiser ici
dans la capitale tunisienne pour le
moment l'ambiance est plutôt bon enfant
ils sont des milliers ici à scander des
slogans positif pour soutenir leur
président de fils pour soutenir le parti
islamiste ennahda pointée du doigt
depuis des semaines
au coeur de cette crise politique
tunisienne